so uh jumping in congrats on being part
of this um i have to ask you what's
cooler uh winning dancing with the stars
or being a voice on star wars oh stop
uh you know they're both great
um
one one required a little more work than
the other i've got to be honest with you
one required weeks of bloody feet and
and uh stress and tears and the torn
cornea but uh i had a beautiful
experience with that yeah this was a
blast man
it was
the way that i love to describe it is
that it was perfectly crafted for me
honestly
it's i'm an anime die hard i've i have
loved everything both canon and none in
the star wars universe for my entire
life
so to be
you know kind of finding my peak in the
voiceover space and and working on so
many different projects and being able
to like
you know really kind of
find my veteranship i guess in that
space and then be offered an opportunity
to not only do
anything for disney
but especially a star wars project
especially
anime
it just
and i get to be a jedi i get to be a
blue lightsaber wielding you know very
forced to swordsmanship balanced
padawan that like kind of has his his
game together a little bit come on
yeah i was i was curious how much you
paid to be in the show
uh i mean i got to shave a couple zeros
off but they they they accepted my final
offer thank god
what i i am curious when you get into
the recording room when
how much did they show you of the
episode how much were they showing you
storyboards what did you actually get to
see before providing your voice the
english dubbing is really interesting um
you know you you have you have
the book it's all there it's it's it's
animated the japanese actors on it
you're doing the thing right so you're
moving to flaps you know they're usually
not totally totally locked with that
project whatever it is if it's an
episode of something or a full film but
um it's
pretty done
and
it's it's a lot of just kind of like
matching intensity and whatnot but
there's a different timing i'm sure that
you know this if you're an anime fan at
all and i've seen a subbed episode or
something and then gone back and watched
the english dub
um
quality tonal quality is is one thing
because it's obviously two different
voices but in terms of choices and
things like that there's still you still
have a little bit of freedom to play
around with delivery and things and uh i
think that is especially the beauty of
visions is having an opportunity to go
through and watch
practically two different versions of
each of these stories um you know with
with
fantastic casts on either side it's a
really awesome thing yeah i can't
imagine um what it's like to be able to
if you're an anime fan being able to be
part of this because it's it's pretty i
mean for people that don't realize i
mean they
this is really cool
100 it's powerful no it was it was
tear-jerking for me honestly because
because it is so specific
it's not only anime it's star wars like
the character looks like you too
come on
yeah what do you think might surprise
people who are not familiar with like
the recording process and doing voices
or voice over work about the actual
process of doing this
wow that's a really really great
question um
that's a great question it's a lot more
mathematical
than a lot of people would think um
because not only the you know
it's already animated so you you do have
to
do things to fit delivery has to fit
however that works out for you and that
being said it has to sound and feel
authentic it has to sound and feel like
you're the one that initiated the
conversation originally and so i think
that regardless of you know something is
originated in one language any actor
that has to take that on afterwards has
to figure out how to you know fit within
the means and the concert because i
don't talk at the same paces as another
person right we have two totally
different speech patterns and cadences
and whatnot and so to kind of reorient
yourself on the spot
and figure out how to say things in ways
that you probably as the human wouldn't
say it but
deliver it in a way that your character
is
within the construct of your window of
time and it's sound legit
it's uh it's
it's it's not it's not easy it's not
easy but
last thing because i know i'm out of
time but i you've done a lot of broadway
work and i'm just curious what what is
the secret to keeping your voice fresh
when you have to do like eight
performances a week and really give
yourself to these things
uh lifestyle you just have to be an
adult you have to really just be an
adult
listen to your body take care of
yourself sleep drink lots of water rest
do get you know make sure that you do
things for yourself that fills you and
restores you i go upstate for a couple
of days often um spend some time with
some family friends up there and just be
in the wilderness in the pool with a dog
then they come back down to the city and
and do what i need to do but truly just
like listening to your body is such a
big that goes for anything travel a lot
for work to use my voice a lot for work
my voice is everything that i do most of
the time
so you just have to
treat it like it's an instrument treat
it like it's a
high-end italian car
you know
on that note congrats on being part of
this i hope you go to sideshow you will
[ __ ] lose your mind i would love to i
really would thank you
have a great day man thank you so much